All right, guys, gather round. Time for the
Week 14 playoff picture
Hey, AB, what do you like better?
Gucci Steampunk Wonka or Prep Schoolboy
With a Secret?
I don't know. They both look pretty stupid
Antonio, can you help me with my toppy-tail?
Hey, Goff, how do I look? Be honest!
Oh you know, below average
Serviceable, I guess? But what are you
gonna do at this point?
Dope, dope
OK, Alex Smith. Move a little further to your left
Further
Is this good?
Perfect
OK, guys, enough silly photos, long shots out
Let's get the real playoff teams back in here
Xavier Rhodes, can you go a little to your right?
You're covering Julio
Damn right I am!
Excuse me, am I even in this thing?
No, not really
OK, on three, everyone, let's say 'the Jags, really?'
HEY, HEY, HEY, NUH, UH, UH, BILLS GUY,
YOU GET OUT
Oh come on, just five quick pics
Would you just sit next to the other
bench quarterbacks?
Eli! We're the same, eh?
Kill me
OK, almost done. Let's just do realistic
contenders only, so Titans you're out
Jags out, Li-, ha, Lions definitely out
Anddd smile